[Music]
now you're launching the fragrance so
what does Kim Kardashian smell like Kim
Kardashian smells like white florals my
favorite scent ever is gardenia so we
are launching three fragrances all
gardenia based we have Krystal gardenia
which is our main scent and then we have
Krystal gardenia citrus and then we have
Krystal gardenia food which I'm really
excited about and the bottle looks like
a crystal beautiful and after my whole
Paris situation over a year ago all my
friends would come over and bring me
healing crystals and I thought wow this
is like I love having them in my home I
love what they mean and I actually feel
really calm and so gardenia also makes
me feel calm that's my favorite flower
it's my favorite scent so I thought my
favorite things the things that are the
most precious to me right now and what's
important in life is just to like be
totally calm and safe and feel like I'm
going through this healing process
that's really beautiful do you feel
healed do you feel better
I do I do it I mean I think everything
and life happens for a reason even if
it's really traumatic and yeah I learn
from it I grow from it and I'm a better
person because of it and I'm doing
totally fine and you listen you're
really good and there's no really really
good
[Music]